no my way when I was young I do remember
there were a lot of drinkers who were
known to be good writers a lot of the
great great writers when I was a kid the
names like William Faulkner was a big
drinker and F scott Fitzgerald who was
one of my favorite writers when I was a
young man and reading fiction for the
first time was notorious drinker and his
wife and then the whole there was there
was a celebration of alcoholism almost
within the creative arts and also an
even in journalism I remember my first
time in the city room of the New York
Times I remember one time one job I had
was working late on what they call the
rewrite desk I was a were you you're on
you're in a rewrite Bank of typewriters
and people call in information well some
of those rewrite men some of them were
so drunk one time I saw a man whose head
fell on his typewriter this is the
center of the New York Times and he he
went he went he was just out out through
the drinking he had a bottle in his
drawer I remember when I was a sports
writer I'm one of the jobs I had in my
early career was working in the sports
department one time I was sent out to
Arizona to cover the New York Giants
baseball team on the year it moved from
New York to San Francisco to become a
San Francisco Giants they trained in
Tucson or Phoenix Arizona and they were
students and I remember I met sports
writers from other newspapers and there
was a sports writer for the New York
News and a sports writer for the New
York mirror which used to be a tabloid
in New York and these two guys who
covered the New York Giants and I was
doing it for the New York time these two
guys were pals and one of them was a
heavy drinker a big drinker his name is
Jim McCullough and the guy there's pal
for the mirrors then Ken Smith ken smith
because McCullough always get drunk
before the game was over would write
both stories he would write a story for
the New York mirror and then he would
write under the name Jim
culluh another story to cover up for his
friend his friend was never able he's
never sober enough the end of the game
to write what happened I mean this was
incredible I couldn't believe this is a
journalism the the journalism that
abounded in my time because and the
presence of alcohol that was part of it
that there's nothing like that today
City room in those days when I have
written with us full of smokers the
whole room was full of smoke and
drinking that they think that now
there's a big series on television
called Mad Men about the advertising
agency life of the 1960s and 70s held
the drinking went on in journalism was
beyond that lunch is at you know drunken
people all over so what do the paper
could ever get out there are enough
sober people at least for every issue to
happen to get a paper out but another
half of the staff was out of it